un mes de Furia en las calles iraníes
desatada tras la muerte de maxa Mini el
16 de septiembre Quien murió tras haber
sido detenida por la policía de la moral
por el uso inapropiado del jayab miles
piden que se ponga fin al uso del velo
islámico y que salgan del poder los
clérigos gobernantes en esta Universidad
de corts Corea van por una sola persona
asesinada a los 3000 detrás
las manifestaciones han sido fuertemente
reprimidas por la policía y según human
right Swatch habría más de un centenar
de Muertos incluyendo menores la Unión
Europea en respuesta emitió nuevas
sanciones contra avances funcionarios
iraníes incluido el jefe de la policía
de la moral
el consejo ha adoptado medidas
restrictivas contra 11 personas y cuatro
entidades
dirigidas a quienes están vinculados a
la muerte de maxam Mini y la represión
de manifestantes pacíficos
pero las marchas no solo se llevan a
cabo en Irán otros países como Canadá
Francia Ecuador o Turquía se han Unido
Quiero la muerte de la República
islámica todo el mundo quiere Eso no se
trata solo del jillap no se trata solo
de las mujeres se trata del régimen
queremos que este régimen desaparezca
hay muchos problemas en mi país amo a mi
país porque iba a vivir aquí en Turquía
porque estoy aquí porque ellos son
Realmente malos
a pesar del desafío para el gobierno de
Irán por estas sanciones y las protestas
incesantes en las calles el sistema
iraní que llegó al poder tras la
revolución islámica en 1979 parece estar
lejos de ser derrocado el líder supremo
sigue acusando a Estados Unidos y a
Israel de estar detrás de un amplio
malestar social que tampoco da signos de
apaciguarse